accompagner les jeunes sans projet c'est
ce que propose le forum sans solution à
la rentrée un événement organisé à
montigny le bretonneux
il permet aux jeunes de rencontrer des
professionnels de la formation et de
l'emploi
l'objectif de ce forum il est de pouvoir
faire bénéficier les jeunes du bassin
saint quentin
et versailles de d'offres d'emploi
d'offres de contrats d'apprentissage de
formation et
qu'ils puissent effectivement un moment
donné s'orienter et
et qu'on puisse leur donner voilà des
outils est aussi vraiment des offres
d'emploi pour pouvoir avancer
suite à cette crise qui a été vraiment
très très très très dur quarante deux
exposants étaient présents sur place
pour l'occasion
objectif proposer aux jeunes service
civique emploi ou encore formation
remplir nos nos classes qui ne sont pas
pleines voilà pour
à la fois nous ça nous permet de les
remplir et puis ça permet de trouver des
solutions pour les jeunes qui n'en n'ont
pas et qui cherche encore des places
dans ces formations là ils peuvent se
renseigner prendre contact et puis
s'inscrire 200 jeunes entre 15 et 20 ans
étaient attendus ils sont venus pour
candidater ou encore se renseigner pour
leurs projets j'ai cherché un emploi ou
un stage en librairie et
j'espère grâce aux organismes comme pôle
emploi ce cahier emploi et la mission
locale ou futurs inscrits pourront
peut-être m'aider en tout cas à trouver
un travail volant stage je me suis
essentiellement renseigner auprès de ces
organismes
il ya plusieurs ya plein de gens
accessibles qui sont là pour répondre à
toutes nos questions notamment bon sky
emploi si j'ai bien compris qui est prêt
qu'il ya plein de choses à proposer donc
avoir pour les recontacter et s'inscrire
sur leur sur leur site un autre forum
sera organisé le mercredi 7 octobre
il se déroulera à la maison des
associations d'aubergenville